he's a journalist activist and author of
the book The Wind in my hair my fight
for freedom in modern Iran masity
alinajad
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
absolutely you're a very brave person
and I I want to get to our of course all
the things we want to talk to you about
today with what's going on in Iran but
let's do it like they do on episodic
shows and start with the most dramatic
scene first and then we'll go five years
early okay so a couple of years ago four
Iranian agents were actually charged in
absentee if with trying to kidnap you
can you believe that I well I'd like to
Okay so
tell us back now why were they trying to
kidnap you what was going on first of
all they're scared of women
and right now that I'm talking to you
they killed a 20 year old woman they
even scared of her hair Masa amini right
but when they came after me here my job
was just giving voice to voiceless women
inside Iran I launched a campaign
against compulsory hijab
because I couldn't cover my hair because
so and then um while I was publishing
videos of women fighting back the
morality police being harassed in the
street filming them that created a huge
anger among more laws because they hate
when they see that women are fighting
back uh hijab police morality police
that's why they try to kidnap me so it's
really silent what we're seeing now in
Iran we've seen for two weeks now and
it's non-stopping apparently all these
demonstrations women have finally had
enough as you said this young woman was
killed in custody taken in by the
morality police they claim some [ __ ]
about pre-existing conditions being she
was a woman I think was the pre-existing
condition and so there's all these riots
people a lot of people have died my
question to you is no we've seen this
before in Iran there was a kind of an
uprising in 2009 we saw the Arab Spring
in 2011 our obviously Persians are not
arid but we're talking about the same
religion yeah
that's behind all this
um is this time going to be different of
course believe me because first of all
um women are burning the head scarf and
this is not just a small piece of cloth
for Iranian women and women in
Afghanistan this is the most visible
symbol of uh a religious dictatorship in
2009 it was about like internal fight
between conservative reformers this time
from the beginning the brutal death of
Masa I mean he created a huge anger
Iranian women not only burning the
headscarf uh they're actually chanting
against the dictators from the first day
so the brutal death of maso I mean it
actually became a turning point for
women who have been pushing back this
gender apartheid regime for years so
right
so take me through what's going to
happen in the next months or years I
mean this regime is just not going to
give up no don't say that bill don't say
that okay we are just going to give up
no because we are we've been seeing
right now for years and years we had the
fear inside us no now this is the moon
lost believe me the Iranian regime
they're really scared of their woman and
um right now this became a Tipping Point
for the Islamic Republic because it's
not just in Iran across the world people
are watching that wow these Fearless
women walking like towards the morality
police and they're ready and and take
top Generations are being killed right
now in the streets so that scares the
regime and I always say that this for
for the Islamic Republic for Taliban
this compulsory job is like the Berlin
Wall
now we're tearing this wall down and the
Islamic Republic won't exist this is the
end of this okay but we
I hope you're right
but
then you mentioned Afghanistan
we pulled out of Afghanistan the Taliban
took over and it went right back to the
bed all day that's why I don't have any
hope on by the administration I don't
have any hope on Western countries they
abandoned my sister in Afghanistan but
guess who came to the streets to support
Iranian women the first group who came
to the street was women of Afghanistan
can you believe that the Western
feminists who actually went to my
country wore hijab they bowed to the
Taliban
they didn't take the streets yet
why are liberals so moronic about the
problem
really this breaks my heart because for
years and years we have been warning
them about the dangers of morality
police you know why because
most of them speak in a perfect English
and they have uh who actually talk about
Islam and Islamic countries they never
go and live under Sharia laws but they
don't even let us talk about our own
experience you know yes I grew up in a
in a country where I was told that if
you show your hair you're gonna go to
jail you will receive lashes you will
get killed like maso amini but here they
tell me that if you talk about this
you're going to cause islamophobia
phobia is irrational but believe me my
fear and the fear of millions of Iranian
women in Afghanistan is rational
yes